j'en ai rat le bol d'entendre ces
comportements
euh euh ces ces vociférations
euh C crit
euh homophobe ça n'a rien à voir dans le
sport
euh j'ai vu récemment ça ça m'a beaucoup
touché le témoignage de Basil
Bolly qui nous a permis d'être champion
d'Europe quand même hein euh et il
expliquait comment il vivait euh les
crit de singe c'est de ça dont on parle
qui lui était adressé le racisme
l'homophobie ça n'a rien à voir dans un
stade et moi je suis tout à fait prêt je
le dis je je je je l'ai évoqué ce matin
avec avec mes équipes là àce que les
types qui se comportent comme ça soit
définitivement interdit de de stade
voilà parce que il y a des gens qui
comprennent rien à rien d'ailleurs je
sais pas si ces gensl aiment le sport
c'est pas possible d'aimer le sport et
puis d'être d'avoir ses ses ses
attitudes de discrimination le sport
c'est c'est le contraire de ça le sport
c'est ce qui unit les gens c'est ce qui
voilà donc je je je je suis prêt à ce
qu'on regarde ça moi je je n'ai pas de
de a priori de comment dirais-je de de
de ligne infranchissable sur la façon
dont on règle ces questions c'est ce que
je vais faire d'ailleurs je vais très
prochainement euh envoyer
euh des gens de chez nous du ministère
en Angleterre parce qu'ils ont connu un
houliganisme de de de d'une
incroyable oui c'était une terreur voilà
ils ont réussi à régler cela euh avec
des mesures drastiques bah s'il faut
aller copier les mesures drastiques on
va y aller c'est c'est infernal tout ça
euh je je je j'avais d'ailleurs souhaité
je je je je vous l'indique je souhaite
qu'on le mette en place que l'on
rappelle sur la sur les billets voyez
les la billetterie les les les termes du
Code pénal en la matière voyez que que
vous jetiez une fusée un projectile sur
le stade que vous balanciez des cris de
singe à un joueur de couleur que je sais
pas quoi que vous criez ce que on
entend dans certains stades ça va stop
stop et stop au moment où on a
auditionné ici je pense à l'association
des supporters sur le foot il y a eu
beaucoup de débats et notamment pendant
longtemps je pense que pour certains ça
existe encore le fait de considérer que
les champs homophobes partie du folklore
dans le dans dans le foot et donc dans
les stades et et d'ailleurs
l'association nous a dit oui mais vous
comprenez pour que un acte soit
condamnable en tant qu'acte homophobe il
faut qu'il y ait
l'intentionnalité dans les propos qui
sont tenus non c'est pas du folklore
c'est écoutez alors alors je vais vous
injurier c'est un folklore Mo tout va
bien ENF ça n'a aucun sens tout ça faut
être sérieux quand même et puis et puis
écoutez-moi bien le folklore c'est fait
aussi pour réunir les gens quand vous
regardez pas vous allez à Perpignan voyz
des gens danser la sardane c'est du
folklore ça réjouit les gens mais là ça
blesse les gens ça blesse les gamins ça
blesse les gens qui qui est homosexuel
qui est un homme de couleur une femme de
couleur enfin c'est il faut il faut
arrêter avec ces trucs là